let me ask a silly sounding
ridiculous sounding but probably
extremely important question
sex and space including intercourse
conception procreation birth
like being a parent
like raising the baby so basically from
birth well from the before the birth
part um like the birds and the bees and
stuff and then the uh the whole thing
how complicated is that i remember
looking at the thank you
i remember looking at this exact
wikipedia page actually and it's i
remember being uh the wikipedia page of
sex and space and fascinating how
difficult of an engineering problem the
whole thing is is that something you
think about too how to have generations
of humans
self
uh self replicating
organizations yes societies essentially
i mean i guess with micro like if you
solve the gravity problem you solve a
lot of these problems that's the hope
yeah it's like this central challenge of
microgravity to human reproduction but
we do host a workshop every year at
beyond the cradle which is the space
event that we run at mit and we always
do one on pregnancy in space or
motherhood or raising children in space
because there are huge questions um
there have been a few mammal studies
that have looked at reproduction in
space but there are still really major
questions about how does it work how
does the fetus evolve in microgravity if
you were pregnant in space and i think
the near-term answer is just going to be
we need to be able to give humans a 1-g
environment for that phase of our
development yeah so there's some studies
on mice in microgravity it's interesting
like i think the mice like one of them
the mice weren't able to walk or like
their understanding of physics i guess
is off or something like that yeah the
mental model when you're really young
and you're kind of
getting your mental model of physics we
do think that that would change
kids abilities to if they were born in
microgravity their ability to have that
intuition around an earth-based 1g
environment might be missing because a
lot of that is really crystallized in
early development early childhood
development
so that makes sense that they would see
that in mice yeah
you